Rochester
thanks for the organizers to allow me to
give this give the stop I want to say
that just a couple of disclaimers the
level of details that I'm going to give
in this talk is not going to be as much
as compared to the other talks we have
seen so far just because if I get into
those details then I'm going to take me
a longer time and I want to sort of get
into the main idea behind like
constructing zero knowledge proof from
multi-party computation alright so first
I'm going to give some motivating slides
on on zero knowledge and well as of
today I mean everyone is interested in
bitcoins and cryptocurrencies and
blockchains and zero knowledge fit right
in as a very useful primitive in in this
space and I'm going to take one aspect
to motivate zero knowledge proof this is
about anonymity now this was one of the
reasons why crypto currencies did get
popular did get popular because of the
promise of anonymity but as we know
classical bitcoins they are not
anonymous in fact there are companies
that do linkage analysis to D anonymize
the Bitcoin watching but you know soon
after you know the right people started
attempting on getting anonymity and
using cryptography one can't fix this
problem well and there were a couple of
works what I'm going to focus on at
least not focus on but what's more
relevant is the Z cash cryptocurrency
that employed zero knowledge proves for
for anonymity so I'm going to sort of
give you a very very simplified view of
this thing if you see the slide it's not
like you're going to you'd be able to
start the next company to do zero
knowledge there's a lot of subtle things
that needs to be taken care off to
really get anonymity you should ask
Alessandro he has experience from the Z
cache too
chillie get this into practice but I
sort of want to just motivate zero
knowledge proof okay so for me
bitcoin is a crypto currency where I'm
going to think of a unit of currency is
a ciphertext and it is identified by a
key who owns the the person who has the
key owns the owns the coin and the
serial number identifies this coin and
for me the blockchain is going to be a
list of ciphertext and transactions okay
so what do we want in such a framework
for anonymity you want to have a nice
mechanism for transferring money from
one person to another in particular what
you want is a mechanism for one party
who is owning the coin to prove to
another party that it owns the coin okay
like I'm I will be able to pay to you
only if I own the coin okay so we want a
mechanism that will allow one party
let's say the coin owner to reveal this
serial number and say that I own this
coin okay
now in the classical Bitcoin framework I
can just you know reveal the key or you
know show other mechanism and point to a
in this list and say this is where I got
my money from okay and this is exactly
what caused the the vulnerability
because I can link transactions okay
so I want to have a proof that I can
show to someone that I have a key and a
ciphertext that this ciphertext is
somewhere in the list of transactions
that you see thus far in the blockchain
and this equation holds that the
ciphertext is the encryption of the
serial number under this key this
exactly proves that I own this coin so I
want a mechanism where one party can
prove such a statement to another party
while hiding everything else okay in
particular you want to prove that
doesn't reveal where my ciphertext is in
this list of transactions
I'm going to give a second example and
here you can think about we all access
websites on a on our browser how to be
authentic 8 that this is a legitimate
website this happens to be through a
mechanism called certificates you get a
certificate a digital certificate from a
certain certificate authority and you
know whenever you load this on your
browser you get this information and you
verify you load this on your browser
only if you have a valid certificate I
mean this has been studied like really
extensively in cryptography it has like
just this basic mechanism has a lot of
vulnerabilities when the certificate
authority is corrupted or there are you
know man-in-the-middle attacks and so
forth so there has been a a drive to get
some form of certificate transparency a
mechanism by which the browser can
validate if there are bad certificates
as well as report that these websites
are in fact bad ok and the idea is that
there is a public log that is maintained
that the certificate authority every
time it issues a certificate should log
this in the log and get sort of a
timestamp from this audit log and this
timestamp is passed along with the
certificate and the browser will check
against this public log that such a
certificate exists or not and if it
doesn't it can report saying that this
is a bad website ok and this is actually
a real thing the certificate
transparency is a project that Google is
involved and there are other companies
that are involved in maintaining such a
public log now the problem in this
picture is that when my browser
recognizes that there is some website
which has an issue I need to report it
but by definition if I have to report
this I have to reveal the website I was
browsing now there are obvious reasons
that I want to keep my website that I'm
accessing private but you can also think
of this as if you are in a company and
you're viewing some sub domain inside
your company you don't want to reveal it
ok you
might not even want other people to know
such a website okay so here what do we
want we want a mechanism for the browser
to show that there is this certificate
issued by some certificate authority
that is not in this public audit log and
you want to do this without revealing in
particular the website that you are
accessing okay so here are two
motivating examples there are many many
applications of zero knowledge I just
pick two of these so what's common
between these two things well in general
you want a mechanism that will allow you
to prove some form of compliance or you
can think of here as a predicate on
sensitive information while keeping the
sensitive information private okay so we
all know what is the predicate that we
want to prove but there is some
sensitive information that goes into
this predicate that we want to hide but
still convinced that this
sensitive information is compliant okay
and the tool that we want to use here is
zero knowledge process introduced by
Bill Watson McCauley and Rakoff in 85
I'm going to go into explaining what our
zero knowledge proof and show some
constructions of how we are going to do
it and if I have some time in the end I
will connect it to probabilistically
checkable proofs that you've been seeing
the last couple of days
again as I said disclaimer its
high-level I'm not going into the
details of for me a proof system
satisfies these three properties through
assertions can be proved false
assertions cannot be proved and it needs
to be easily verifiable okay if we
didn't have the third condition than
proof systems don't make sense because I
can just ask you to do it yourself to
check whether some statement is true or
false and for our purposes here easily
verified at least from a computer
science perspective you're going to say
it needs to be verifiable in
probabilistic polynomial-time so in this
in this aspect what do zero-knowledge
proves do well I want to say one way to
view it is it is sort of a compiler that
takes proofs that you can verify with
private information and transform it
into proofs that helps you verify the
same thing without the private
information okay so slightly more
formally you should think of it as an
interaction between approver and a
verifier where the prover has some
statement that it wants to prove to the
verifier and just to be you know to make
the discussion simple you can think of X
as some empty statement okay and it
needs to satisfy three properties
completeness which says that P can
convince the prover can convince the
verifier whenever the statement is true
which means that it has say a valid NP
witness for example soundness says that
no proven should be able to convince the
verifier if X is not true okay here
again there are many variants some of
which that Alessandro told in the
morning you can have you can ask that no
unbounded prover or no computationally
bounded prover can convince the verifier
if X is not true and you get proofs or
arguments correspondingly
and the last thing zero knowledge says
that no efficient verifier can learn
anything more than the validity of the
statement okay and we've already seen
completeness and soundness over the past
two days what I want to focus on is the
zero knowledge property
so first let me just give you a
classical example on one of the first
zero knowledge proves for the statement
of graph isomorphism so here what do we
have both the proven and the verifier
have as input the have two graphs and
the prover wants to convince the
verifier that these two graphs are
isomorphic so let's say that the prover
has this witness that demonstrates that
these two graphs are isomorphic a simple
way to convince would be for the prover
to just simply give hand over this
isomorphism that shows the mapping of
vertices from one to another and the
verifier will be convinced but such a
proof system is not zero knowledge in
particular it reveals a lot of
information about this isomorphism
itself between the two graphs so here
we're going to come up with an
interactive system which is sort of
going to hide this isomorphism between
the graphs G 0 and G 1 so how does this
protocol proceed the first step the
prover is going to pick say G 0 and
randomly permute the vertices over here
to get a new graph H ok so when I say
randomly permute just think of it as
relabeling the vertices of the graph by
applying a random permutation ok and it
constructs this graph H gives it to the
very file now the verifier is going to
challenge 0 or 1 depending on what
challenge the verifier gives the prover
needs to demonstrate that either G 0 is
isomorphic to H or G 1 is isomorphic to
H ok so let's quickly see why this is
complete sound and zero knowledge so
it's complete because an honest prover
that has the isomorphism from G 0 to G 1
will always be able to answer give the
right answer in the third round because
the prover actually constructed H let's
say from G 0 if the challenge was 0 then
it can just give this isomorphism but if
the challenge was 1 it needs to get the
isomorphism from G 1 but this is easy
because it knows the isomorphism from G
0 to G 1 so it can compose the ice
morphism from H to G 0 and G 0 to G 1
and get the isomorphism between H and G
1 okay so this protocol is complete and
that the prover can always convince the
verifier when it knows the isomorphism
between G 0 and G 1 some nests on the
other hand can be easily argued by
observing that no matter what h the
prover gives to the verifier it can be
isomorphic to at most one of the two
graphs because if it was isomorphic to
both graphs they where isomorphic to
begin with so since it can be isomorphic
to at most one of the two graphs there
is always a challenge on which it's
going to fail so the soundness of this
proof system is at least a half ok now
zero knowledge I'm going to sort of hand
wave here to see that what did the what
does the verifier learn in this
computation well in an interaction over
here it either learns an isomorphism
between G 0 and some random graph H or
it learns and isomorphism between G 1
and a random graph H this is what it
sees in an interaction with the prover
and this reveals like as you can see I
mean again I'm hand waving it doesn't
reveal any explicit connection between G
0 and G 1 itself ok this can be formally
argued I want to now get into how does
one formally define zero knowledge proof
so again little high-level but this is
sort of the formal definition of a zero
knowledge proof system you're going to
say that an interactive proof system is
zero knowledge if for every efficient
verifier and an efficient verifier is
captured by probabilistic
polynomial-time Turing machine for every
efficient verifier that is a efficient
or probabilistic polynomial-time
simulator that can simulate the view of
the very fire against the prover so
let's see a little more carefully what
this means so what happens in a real
interaction
well the verifier exchanges messages
with the prover and you know might also
toss coins in this in the process
now the zero knowledge definition wants
to capture the fact that these things
that the verifier receives during the
interaction doesn't carry any
information okay doesn't carry any
information beyond the fact that this
statement is true in the case of graph
isomorphism you want to say that the
messages don't carry anymore information
beyond the fact that these two graphs
are isomorphic okay so to show that such
a thing is zero knowledge you construct
a simulator that can generate something
that looks like this and in particular
it needs to do this without knowing the
witness okay this seems this seems funny
but if we can show that for every
verifier there is a simulator that can
generate this that looks like what it
would see in a real interaction with the
prover then we can conclude that
whatever the verifier says it's going to
learn from this it could have as well
learn it learnt from the simulators
output okay I think this can be
mathematically formalized I'm not
getting into this over here one needs to
define these are actually they are not
you know you cannot just say this is
equal to this this is actually a
distribution and you need to sort of
compare two distributions and talk about
what does it mean to say that two
distributions are the same or
indistinguishable okay
so but this is the definition of zero
knowledge it says that for every
verifier that claims to say that look I
learned something during an interaction
with the prover that is a simulator that
could have generated the same view okay
and here by view of the verifier I'm
talking about what the verifier sees
during the interaction with an honest
proof
so the rational again as I said before
behind this definition is that the
verifier learns nothing beyond what it
could have learnt on its own okay and
here when we say that what the verifier
itself we are going to restrict
ourselves to you know whatever it can
learn in probabilistic polynomial-time
so you should imagine here that how do
you convince yourself that this proof
system is zero knowledge the idea is
that if a malicious verifier is
interacting with the proven and it's
trying to claim that look your proof
system is actually revealing more than
what it should be then you imagine this
very fire could run you can imagine
another party or the verifier itself
running the simulator and producing
these messages and learning the same
information and here the verify learnt
this information without the prover in
particular without the witness so it
learned that information without the
sensitive information at least what we
think of the the prover hat okay and
here there is sort of a subtle point
when we say that we want to say that the
verifier does not learn anything more
than the validity of the statement here
one needs to be careful there are some
simple things that you can always learn
from from your statement it's not like
zero knowledge protects against
everything that you can learn from a
proof system it can only protect against
things that are not free and what is
free free is probabilistic
polynomial-time computation anything
that I can learn from the statement in
probabilistic polynomial-time is for
free it's only things beyond
probabilistic polynomial-time that we
can protect against zero knowledge okay
and the the problem graph isomorphism is
a good instance because we don't know
whether graph isomorphism can be done in
polynomial time okay so it is it is
meaningful to ask to protect the
isomorphism in your interactive proof
system
everyone with me so far okay so zero
knowledge proof again a little bit
motivation slide here is that zero
knowledge proof they sort of introduced
and was the cornerstone of modern
definitions of security it introduced
the simulation paradigm that helps you
argue and define security of
cryptographic primitives not just that
it also the the ways in which you have
you prove an interactive proof is zero
knowledge also provided techniques to
prove other primitives are secure in
particular the simulation paradigm
through rewinding which I won't get into
was an important contribution towards
developing cryptographic primitives and
of course zero knowledge is you know a
cryptographic building block we've known
since the 80s but now you know people
are trying to use this as much as
possible so what can you prove using
zero knowledge I gave you a simple proof
system for graph isomorphism but graph
isomorphism again we don't know if it is
np-complete meaning can it be used to
prove any NP statement in fact we have
evidence to show that it might not be
np-complete but what can we prove using
zero knowledge well soon after zero
knowledge proof sware introduced the
work of garage McCauley and victors and
show that you can prove zero knowledge
proof for all of NP okay and the theorem
statement basically says that if you
have this cryptographic object that we
call bit commitments then you can
construct a zero knowledge proof for all
of NP and I'm going to show this proof
in a you know in a few slides but just a
quick word about bit commitments
whenever I say commitments just for a
mental note you can think of it as just
using some sort of collision resistant
hash function on whatever message I'm
talking about
but MIT commitments formally are sort of
a digital equivalent of a sealed
envelope it helps one person to commit
to some information digitally to another
person in such a way that I can
transform
message to the string that will not
reveal anything about the message but at
a later point of time when the person
says tell me what you committed I cannot
change it so it satisfies two properties
one is hiding which says that I can
transform my message into this string
that hides my message and it is also
binding in that at a later point of time
if the person who had the string asks me
tell me what I committed I cannot change
my mind about it okay so this is this
property is called binding so if I have
a big commitment scheme then I can get
zero knowledge proof for all of NP in
fact you can have bit commitment these
hiding and binding properties one of
these two properties can also be
satisfied against say an unbounded
adversity so but what can you like so
this is good but how do you what do you
need to construct bit commitment schemes
so it's a cryptographic object and it
was shown in a sequence of works after
that that one may functions which is
sort of the minimal assumption that you
need for cryptography is enough to
construct a big commitment so now we
know that just one wave functions are
sufficient to construct zero knowledge
proves for all of NP okay so one can ask
you know I see that this is the smallest
sort of thing primitive that we want in
in in cryptography can we do better well
actually that is a lower bound that sort
of says that if you have zero knowledge
proof for certain languages like hard on
the average languages then it implies
some form of one-way functions so in
some sense one-way function is sort of
the minimal thing that we need to
construct zero knowledge proof okay so
for the rest of the talk I am going to
focus on zero knowledge proof for for NP
but I do want to point out that you can
do zero knowledge proof for beyond NP in
fact it was shown that everything
provable is provable in zero knowledge
meaning anything that has an interactive
proof system as we saw yesterday that
all of P space
as an interactive proof system any
language that has an interactive proof
system can be compiled into a proof
system that is additionally zero
knowledge beautiful works I encourage
all of you to let go and read the read
the classics but today we are going to
start to focus on zero knowledge for all
of NP so first I'm going to talk about
the classical classical construction of
zero knowledge so we saw this problem
Prolog introduced the problem of graph
three coloring we know graph three
coloring is an np-complete problem I'm
going to give you a zero knowledge proof
system for graph three coloring and then
do the normal computer science I think
to say that everything in NP can be
reduced in graph three coloring so I'm
done okay so what do we want to doing in
graph three coloring here we have a
scenario where both the prover and the
verifier have a graph as input and the
prover additionally has a three coloring
of this graph and the prover wants to
convince to the verifier that it has a
three coloring of this graph okay so I'm
going to give you the proof system and
argue why it is zero knowledge and as I
mentioned before I will need this
cryptographic object called commitments
so what is the prover have so the common
statement that the prover and the
verifier have is the graph the prover
additionally has a witness that it is
trying to protect which will be the
coloring of the graph okay in the first
step what's the prover going to do well
the prover is going to permute the
coloring of the graph it has one kind of
like three coloring of this graph it's
just going to reel able these coloring
say you know great or black black to
gray and keep red unchanged I'm going to
at the end of this I'm going to ask you
why this permuting is is important but
let's go on with the protocol so in the
first step the prover takes the graph
takes its coloring and just does a
relabeling of this coloring then the
prover is going to commit to the
coloring of each of the nodes of the
graph and send it to the verifier okay I
didn't go into the details of how a
commitment is constructed from one wave
function so forth there are interactive
protocols there are non interactive
protocols but for here just imagine it's
easier to think about a non-interactive
commitment scheme meaning the prover can
take each string that it wants to commit
and convert it to like a string that
will serve as the commitment for that
message or string okay so the prover
takes this relabeled colors of the graph
commits to each one of them separately
and sends it to the verify this is the
first message now the verifier is going
to say okay I want to see whether you
know you really committed to a3 coloring
I'm going to pick a random edge in this
graph and I'm going to ask you to reveal
the colors incident on this edge so as
we said commitments have this property
they are hiding as such when I see these
things they're just a sealed envelope I
don't know anything but then later when
I ask the prover to open it it cannot
cheat whatever it sent me in the first
round it better reveal exactly what was
committed in these things so the
verifier is going to say I'm going to
pick a random edge in this graph and ask
the prover to open the coloring of the
nodes incident on this edge
so the prover does this and then the
verifier is happy as long as as long as
these colors are different remember if
it's a valid three coloring no edge can
be incident on nodes of the same color
okay so this is the proof system so the
verifier accepts if both the colors are
valid and distinct okay and rejects
otherwise so this is a zero knowledge
proof system and let's see why
I mean first completeness completeness
holes because the prover has a valid
coloring it will honestly commit to the
colors it will real Abel the colors and
honestly give these colors in the
commitments when the verifier opens any
edge the edge is going to be incident or
nodes with valid colorings and distinct
okay and sonís on the other hand holds
here if I start with the graph that is
not 3 colorable then it must be the case
that no matter what coloring the prover
gives me at in the in the first step
there must be at least one edge that is
that doesn't that have the same color
okay well either the prover is going to
try to commit to garbage or if it did
commit to like valid colorings but you
know some edge must have the same two
colors okay
and since the verifier picks a random
edge when it challenges the prover there
is a 1 over e 1 over the number of edges
probability with which it's going to
catch so the soundness of this proof
system is 1 minus 1 over e ok and zero
knowledge what do we have to do in zero
knowledge well you need to construct
sort of a simulator that can simulate
this this view now recall that the
simulator does not have the the valid
three coloring and it still needs to
generate the view and the idea roughly
speaking is going to be that the
simulator is going to guess the edge
that the verifier is going to ask and
it's going to build a commitment scheme
such that at least this edge that I
guessed has different colors ok and
just hopes that the verifier picks this
edge now that seems unreasonable the
probability that I'm going to win is
going to be small so it's not clear that
I can do it but the power that the
simulator has here is that it is trying
to show that some verifier does not
learn anything more it can actually
remind the verifier so what the
simulator is going to do is it's going
to just keep trying it's going to guess
what edge the verifier picks and it's
going to make a commitment so that these
two colorings are on that edge is
different and hope that the verifier
asks this since these commitments are
hiding the verifier cannot base its
decision based on these commitments the
verifier will not know where the
simulator quote endquote has cheated so
in this sense the the simulator as I
said is going to guess which edge the
verifier picks is going to cheat in the
commitments on that edge and hope that
the verifier asks this edge and if it
doesn't it's just going to try all over
again and now you can ask well you need
the simulator to be polynomial time how
many times do I have to rewind since the
verifier cannot guess exactly what I'm
doing in expectation my simulator needs
to run order edges number of times until
it it hits the guests that the verifier
is going to ask with correctly okay
again all of this can be formalized I'm
sort of giving you a high level of how
one actually constructs a simulator for
for this scheme but as I mentioned I
wanted to ask you why was it necessary
that you needed to permute these colors
before the prover commits anyone
right so it's not just that but also
that I mean if I did come into the
actual coloring you learn something
about my coloring right so if you permit
it it is equally likely to be any two
distinct colors okay and this also I
mean it comes out in the simulation
where the simulation needs to simulate
the same behavior but this is sort of
crucial to construct the zero knowledge
proof system okay now this is great we
have constructed a zero knowledge proof
system for graph three coloring we got
completeness it holds with probability 1
and soundness is 1 minus 1 over E that's
a little bit unsatisfying right 1 minus
1 over E is bad soundness so how do we
bring this down well there are standard
techniques but you can repeat this proof
system over and over again and bring and
bring the soundness down you have to
repeat it order e times or a little
order e times to get constant but a
little more if you want to get
negligible soundness okay and here I'm
not going to get into the detail one
could ask can I repeat it parallel e as
opposed to sequentially and what I'm
talking about here is sequential e
because parallely we still don't know
it's an open problem to prove whether if
I repeat it in parallel is it zero
knowledge ok this is a big open question
whether when I repeat the zero knowledge
protocol in parallel does the soundness
go down and is it zero knowledge yes and
graph isomorphism is polynomial time
solvable would they be a problem or
so the question is that if something
becomes in polynomial time then the
disease as zero knowledge proof system
as I send you nothing because you could
learn everything on your own I just
don't need to send you anything so it
that just becomes a trivial zero
knowledge system it's like asking can I
get a zero knowledge system for bpp
yes one comment just actually you may
still not clear in the air cover so that
you still may have something even if
it's in polynomial time
yeah yes so as I said if you look here
how do I do zero knowledge I actually
guess your edge right so and how many
times do I have to rewind to guess your
age 1 over edge order 1 over edge in
expectation right now if I repeat it in
parallel I have to make correct guesses
in all of the parallel executions so if
I want negligible soundness I'll have to
repeat it at least so many times and
then my simulator becomes exponential
time so but that does go to the point
that you can achieve parallel if I allow
my simulation to be exponential time and
that relates something called witness
indistinguishability but that's a weaker
property than zero now okay so here yes
yeah because yes you are right it is
because the verifier we have to deal
with malicious verifiers that could base
its decision of opening an edge on
arbitrary things this is honest verify
of zero knowledge when you repeat it in
parallel it is honest verifier zero yes
but honest verifier it is fine
all right so just a couple of things I
want to point out in this thing as I
said the computer science II thing is to
say game over I've done it for all of NP
because I've done it for graph three
coloring but if you go into like okay
really I want to use these protocols
zero knowledge proof in practice one
thing is that is car production and car
production to graph three coloring is
going to be no one I think I know of has
ever implemented it from an arbitrary NP
statement to graph three coloring and
sunless amplification is also an issue
because if I I don't want one minus one
over a soundness I want negligible
soundness which means I'll have to
sequentially repeat this order e times
and this is also not good in practice
okay so now what I'm going to do is so
this is zero knowledge for all of NP and
now I'm going to give you another way of
constructing zero knowledge for all of
NP which are going to help address some
of these and give you much more richer
kind of zero knowledge proof systems so
this is zero knowledge via secure
multi-party computation so before I get
into this construction I have to tell
you what is secure multi-party
computation so bear with me for a few
slides I want to tell you what secure
computation is okay so what is secure
computation well secure computation
allows a set of parties p1 through P and
that each individually have private
inputs x1 through xn and they all want
to learn some function jointly over
their private inputs in such a way that
they learn only the output and nothing
else ok so
I've been talking to a few people about
you know this MPC technology and
practice and often what I say is that
zero knowledge helps protecting privacy
when you have only one one entity that
has a privacy requirement but when you
want privacy for multiple parties you
sort of need secure computation so in
secure computation what you have is you
have a set of parties each having their
own private sensitive information and
they want to jointly compute functions
over their inputs over their sensitive
input you can if you want to have a
simplified picture you can imagine they
all have the same function okay in a
classic example that people talk about
here is auctions okay you have people
bidding they don't want to reveal their
bid and the function that you want to
compute is the person with the highest
bid okay and you want a protocol where
these parties can compute this function
just within themselves where they learn
the output and nothing else and this is
exactly what secure computation
facilitates so how does one formalize
secure computation I'm going to give you
a one slide sort of thing the way you do
it is by comparing what happens in a
real world with what happens in an ideal
world so the first step in defining
secure computation is sort of to define
what you think you would what sort of
security properties would you like in an
ideal world and the way it's usually
formalized is by saying that there is
some trusted entity that receives the
input from all parties and then does the
computation correctly and reveals the
answer okay this is what you want
ideally okay and you want to say that
what happens in the real world is as
correct and as private as the ideal
world in other words I first define an
ideal world with all my security
requirements and in my ideal world you
know it doesn't exist but I can say that
I have a trusted party that does all the
computations correctly and keeps the
information private okay so I want a
real world protocol between the parties
that is as correct and as private as the
ideal world so the way you formally
define this is to say that
this protocol protects against all
adversaries in the real world such that
for every adversary in the real world I
can show that there is an adversary
let's call this adversary the simulator
in the ideal world that can carry out
the same attack you can already see the
flavor here it's similar to zero
knowledge in some sense so what this
what the definition of secure
computation is saying is that a protocol
is considered secure if you can provide
a mechanism that for every adversary in
the real world
that is trying to attack your protocol
that is an equivalent ideal adversary or
adversary in the ideal world that can
launch the same attack if you can
provide such a reduction then your
protocol is secure in the sense that you
already defined what are the set of
attacks that are possible in the ideal
world you said this is ideally what I
want in here and now you show that the
set of attacks that an adversary can do
on your protocol in the real world is
restricted to the attacks that can be
done in the ideal world and I should
point out that here the the attacks in
the ideal world I mean there are attacks
that you can do in the ideal world if I
go and hack this person I can in fact
change the input of this person okay and
this we consider is legitimate so in
secure computation this is not
necessarily protected and what is also
not protected is what the function
itself reveals okay so these are two
aspects that are sort of orthogonal to
what secure computation gives over here
for example if the function itself
reveals some part of your input it's not
like a secure computation can protect
against it okay so you define what
function you want to learn and then a
secure computation can deliver the
security that everyone will learn
exactly what this function computes and
nothing more okay so this is secure
computation in a slide and now what we
want to talk about is can we construct
z0 knowledge from secure computation and
i'm going to say that all these like
wonderful
thing zero knowledge proves and there
were many works in multi-party
computation dubbed as MPC over here in
the 80s and the question sort of here is
are these things in fact related okay I
want to point out that both zero
knowledge proof and multi-party
computation have different flavors that
I'm not going into for example as
Alessandro said there are proofs versus
arguments you can talk about they you
can talk about security against an
unbounded through versus security
against an unbounded verifier and
similarly even in MPC there are all
these flavors computational says that
the security you achieve at the end of
the day is not against unbounded
adversaries but only bounded adversaries
you can talk about in a in a multi-party
setting you can talk about how many
parties can my adversary attack ok and
there are two distinct classes here
honest majority and dishonest majority
honest majority says that an adversity
can at any point of time corrupt or hack
less than half of the parties ok and
dishonest majority says the adversity
can corrupt up to all but one of the of
the parties now there's also a third
kind here where you can get so this
dichotomy is also important from an
assumptions point of view so for honest
majority MPC one can actually construct
this without any cryptographic
assumptions like I said for zero
knowledge you need one wave functions
here in the unconditional regime there
are situations where I can construct
these protocols without any
cryptographic assumptions but if I want
to construct something beyond honest
majority which means the adversary can
corrupt all but one of these parties I
necessarily have to use assumptions ok I
have to use some form of cryptographic
assumption to do this with one exception
here being this is a model that sort of
helps you abstract things out you can
actually get unconditional MP
meaning security against unbounded
adversaries if every pair of party have
access to what we call an ideal
oblivious transfer Oracle okay I'm just
going to do a very quick word this is
not going to be relevant if you don't
know it's fine what is an oblivious
transferred Oracle you should I lost my
picture nevermind maybe I can quickly
tell you what is a of livius transferred
Oracle it is if I have two parties I'm
going to call SN R s has two inputs s 0
and s 1 and R has a bit B and every pair
of party have an access to what we call
an oblivious transfer Oracle that takes
us input as 0 and s 1 from s that we
call the sender and B that we call from
the receiver and gives s B it is sort of
an ideal object that implements
something like a multiplexer okay so if
every pair of party have parties have
access to such an Oracle that can
ideally perform this functionality then
we can actually get unconditional
multi-party computation in this world ok
this is just an abstraction that helps
us develop protocols it is not like in
when we actually implement this protocol
that there is someone who will who will
do this ok so why did I get into all of
these is because I want to talk about
how to construct zero knowledge proof
from multi-party computation so first
there is an obvious way of constructing
zero knowledge from secure multi-party
computation as I said before zero
knowledge is like situations where only
one party is private in secure
computation which were multiple parties
I'll have you know privacy requirements
you can just think of zero knowledge as
an instance of secure computation so
think of two parties their inputs are
it's X comma W for the proper X for the
verifier and the output is basically the
the output of the relation on the
approvers input I mean you can also just
do a little bit check that this is the
statement X and that this is the
relation X and W outputs 1 ok so here is
a simple way of constructing if you give
me a secure computation protocol for all
functions instantiate secure computation
with this function and you get a zero
knowledge proof system this is very easy
ok but what is the problem with this
well as I mentioned to you before you
need a secure computation protocol for
two parties now secure computation for
two parties necessarily has to be in the
dishonest majority setting you are not
going to get an honest majority with two
people you need at least three or more
parties which means that these protocols
will require cryptographic assumptions
and if I instantiate zero knowledge in
this approach I'm going to inherit all
the assumptions that were required for
secure computation and secure
computation also requires more
assumptions than zero knowledge just to
make sort of a distinction zero
knowledge can be done from symmetric key
primitives like one-way functions hash
functions are enough to do zero
knowledge but secure computation in this
regime requires public key assumptions
okay so instantiate in this way is going
to make us inherit all these these
assumptions as well as the
inefficiencies of secure property so
what we're going to do is we're going to
consider a different approach that's
going to give us much better features
okay so the idea here is going to be to
the goal is we want to construct the
zero knowledge proof for some relation
now we're going to consider an NPC a
multi-party computation for this bizarre
functionality
what is this functionality it is an end
party functionality where it takes
inputs from n parties it takes W one
through W n from the end parties it adds
them up and evaluates the relation and
reveals this okay so it's a
essentially the relations slightly
modified okay so we are going to
consider a multi-party computation for
this function where n parties supply
their inputs and the the the multi-party
computation gives you the evaluation of
the relation on this X is given to
everybody X is public now what are the
security features that we will need in
on the multi-party computation actually
very very minimal okay you want it to be
too secure meaning that it's enough to
consider an MPC where the adversary
corrupts at most two parties okay the
more the more number of parties that you
corrupt the NPC gets more complicated so
if I just want security up to two
corruptions this is this is like really
minimal and the MPC protocol me needs to
be secure in what we call this is yet
another flavor of MPC where we talk
about security against adversities that
follow the protocol as opposed to
adversaries that don't follow the
protocol this is called semi honest
security where I only care about
adversaries that will you know they're
just honest but curious they are going
to corrupt parties look at what's
happening and try to learn more okay so
I need an MPC protocol for this function
G that is to secure that is secure just
against semi honest adversaries and
honest majority is fine I get the
flexibility of choosing what n will be
but if I want honest majority and to
security the number of parties I need to
handle is at least for at least 5 ok so
I'm going to show how to construct semi
honest says that I just need to show
that my protocol is private against
adversaries that can corrupt whatever
threshold set of parties that
you-you-you set but it will follow the
protocol honestly it will not deviate
well it's not Byzantine in that sense
and you just want sort of privacy if you
saw if you recall in the
so it not no inputs also it doesn't
corrupt anything like it can still try
to so I mean it's still non-trivial to
construct against that adversaries
because you need privacy against those
parties right like you're saying that
look I'm constructing this protocol
against these parties that if I see two
or three of them maybe I learn
everything so even if it follows the
protocols there is something non-trivial
to be shown in these things but it is
barely minimal like this is like very
minimal requirements on the MPC protocol
and I also want to sort of say that this
can be constructed unconditionally I
don't need any assumptions for this
setting and for people who know
something like bgw like this is like
even passive bgw is something that's
enough to instantiate this MPC protocol
okay so let's take an MPC protocol that
is to secure perfectly correct and I'll
tell you why we need perfectly correct
and then I'll tell later how this can be
relaxed perfectly correct essentially
says that that isn't bad randomness that
if these parties somehow choose they
will get the incorrect answers so
perfect correctness just rules out this
case okay so now this is sort of the
punchline if you forgot if you didn't
listen to anything in this talk I'm
going to show how to construct a zero
knowledge proof system from MPC and this
was done in in the beautiful work of
issue I crucial awaits Ostrovsky and
Sahai
I think it was in 2007 the journal
version was 2009 okay so the goal
construct zero knowledge for this
relation consider this modified
functionality that does a slightly
different thing before it computes the
relation so what is the proof system we
have approval the prover in her head is
going to simulate the execution of this
MPC protocol in particular what it is
going to do it's going to consider end
parties it's going to distribute take W
and then break it into W 1 through W and
give it as input to these parties P 1
through P and and emulate this MPC in
her head
okay meaning just you know run the next
message algorithm of each one of these
parties in her head and you know sort of
just collect the log of this entire
execution then what the pruvit is going
to do well the prover is going to let VI
be the view of PII and view basically is
the transaction log from my point of
view if I was participating in the
protocol and if you want a little more
precisely it is all the messages I
exchanged in the protocol and my input
and randomness that I used and so the
prover does this and then now takes the
view of each of these parties in the
first message you're going to see now
the parallel to graph three coloring but
if the prover is going to commit to the
views of each of these parties okay now
the verifier is going to take and is
going to challenge to open a couple of
these commitments it's going to pick two
I and J from the set of parties and ask
open these up okay and the prover will D
commit or open the message is committed
in VI and VJ what's the verifier going
to do it's going to check consistency
between these two it's going to check
two things it's going to check whether
the output of the computation was one
this is important because I need to know
that the relation turned out to be one
that's the whole goal I want to make
sure that the relation on X comma W that
exists at W such that the relation on X
comma W is one and it's going to check
if the view of VI and VJ are consistent
what does this mean the message is sent
from VI was logged correctly in both VI
and VJ the messages exchanged between
these two parties and if these two
conditions hold the verifier accepts
okay and this is the zero knowledge
proof system let's just quickly see
completeness will hold because if the
relation is true on this witness then
it's easy for the prover to emulate this
multi-party computation and you know to
get this this is called the XOR sharing
but it's easy to get random W 1 through
W N
that they add up to W you just pick NY n
- one of them at random and make the
last one the difference of W and the sum
okay so the prover can do this all the
views are consistent because the prover
emulated the NPC correctly which means
no matter which - I and J the the
verifier picks the prover will be able
to decommitted correctly okay now some
nests on the other hand is going to be 1
minus 1 over N choose 2 1 minus 1 over n
Square and roughly the point is that if
if the statement was not true then it
means that there is no set of W 1
through W n that will make this output 1
which means that no matter what the
prover tries to do there must be some
two of these parties that are
inconsistent ok you cannot generate a
view that is going to output this and
here is where you're going to use
perfect correctness there is no way in
which you can set up these input and
randomness for parties to make a wrong
answer ok so no matter what the prover
submits there has to be two views for
which this it's not going to be
consistent according to the MPC protocol
and the probability with which the
verifier is going to catch that is 1
over n choose 2 okay so that's soundness
and zero knowledge and here again at
least when I write this this is the
beautiful part zero knowledge is
typically hard to you know doing these
settings here the zero knowledge aspect
actually follows from the simulation of
the MPC ok what is a multi-party
computation give multi-party computation
says for every adversary in the real
world there is a simulator in the ideal
world that can sort of simulate the
views of the adversary so what the
simulator is going to do is going to
guess I comma J and then it's going to
just commit to VI and VJ that are
consistent and how do i construct VI and
VJ that is consistent I'll just call the
simulator ok and I can call the
simulator to construct VI VJ
I can do this and this is like very
similar to the graph 3 coloring that we
saw that you know I will remind until my
guess is right and then I can simulate
this ok so everyone with me sort of the
complete the the soundness and the zero
knowledge security properties of the
zero knowledge system follows in some
sense directly from the properties of
the MPC protocol ok but then you know I
did all this and then finally I still
get something like really the soundness
is not good
I sort of like did a huge build-up
saying graph three coloring as bad
soundness and so forth but we're going
to see how this is going to be useful
but I want to sort of point out that
this is sort of a more natural way of
constructing zero knowledge proof system
because constructing an MPC protocol for
a function this is something that is
more natural than doing sort of a car
production to graph three coloring you
only depend directly on the function and
when we talk about efficiency of these
things you can directly relate the
efficiency of the MPC protocol to the
efficiency of the zero knowledge proof
system
naturally so one big problem and then
you say I reduce it to somebody racial
so it's natural in the sense okay well I
mean I can give that the technical thing
is that one doesn't have to know the
internals of this function so to speak I
can just say construct any arbitrary MPC
for this function can be plugged in over
here and this is not something like all
the other things really required to you
know engineer these things in some sense
well maybe it's not natural matter of
taste okay but maybe ask so so right
good so let me just go a little more
detail like oh I'm running out of time
okay good good okay so let's take that
offline I'll I'll just sort of I have
just two more slides and I'll be done
with that okay so I think I have only
two two more slides something that will
come maybe more in the next talk this is
an interactive version if you want
something non interactive one can apply
the Fiat Shamir heuristic to these two
these protocols there are extensions as
I said this is just a framework you can
translate any MPC protocol to to zero
knowledge you can even here I said I
need at least to secure you can also do
one secure protocols here you just have
to commit different things you have to
commit two views and also communications
channels separately and you can consider
even one secure MPC which allows you to
instantiate with other protocols you can
also handle MPC with error I sort of
told you that I needed it to be
perfectly correct you can also do things
that are statistically secure and in
fact doing this helps you get better
efficiency you can also do things that
if the MPC protocol employs oblivious
well you can still use that as your as
your basic MPC protocol to do the zero
knowledge and not inherit the
assumptions required for ot this is also
possible and you get some additional
kind of features for for these kind of
transformations and the last slide
simple zero knowledge proof so you can
instantiate with bgw one out of three
you can instantiate with the gmw in the
OT hybrid these are very simple zero
knowledge systems that you can get in
fact this has been implemented and even
to date for like some kind of the
circuit regimes the prover complexity of
these things are much better than the
things that we know of and there have
also been
candidates for post quantum signatures
that have come like from zero knowledge
proof so you can get digital signatures
and there have been this work actually
gives the last two works give post
quantum signatures from this kind of
zero knowledge proof from MPC in the
head you can get asymptotically
efficient zero knowledge proof if I give
you only big commitments or one-way
functions you can ask what is the best
communication complexity that we know
you can just instantiate it by giving
the right MPC protocol you can get zero
knowledge with corresponding efficiency
features I have some work here which
shows that this can actually be
practically efficient and get sublinear
proof systems you can also this is this
is one of the nice features like if I
want to do an m0 knowledge for some
function that has some different
representation some different
computational model if I have the right
NPC for that functionality maybe it's
over rings maybe it's over groups then I
can instantiate that NPC to get a good
zero knowledge system thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes so no so you can so gettin
negligible soundness there are there are
ways to make the parallel repetition
work it loses the property of there are
multiple ways of getting it but if you
just want it from bit commitments then
you need to make it private coin and you
can make it this is gold rake kahan like
you can construct something even
parallel repetition works but with MPC
you can do something slightly better but
it still becomes private coin another
way to do it is get honest verify zero
knowledge and apply Fiat Jimmy this is
another way that you can get zero
knowledge you don't need to do the the
sequential repetitions
no you just make the verifier commit to
the challenge and then open it this is
gold right kahan like essentially so
that's why it becomes private coin so
because then I don't have to guess
because if the verifier commits to the
challenge before the prover gives then
you know the verifier opens I can rewind
and then now I know where to cheat again
it doesn't work there's some work needs
to be done there it's not like gold icon
was like like sorry
oh I see okay
yes okay go that's it a slide with a key
Senor hey so I feel like if I were
trying to design this from scratch I'll
be pretty confused of N squared and
here's why so I think the more natural
thing to do is I pick one of the pie all
the input that goes into it and it's
internal thinking process yes I like
kind of pick the web around a single
evidence right I could make it like look
if you're saying that I open only the
view of one party like this process so
you're but that is the view right I mean
there is nothing more than that what do
you mean by beyond the view that is I
mean the view contains incoming and
outgoing messages and the input and
random view and so that's how you do one
secure that is right you could do that
as well correct
yes you can make that like with you
could make it 1-1 over it but the better
thing to do the better thing there are
other ways like if I consider T out of n
for larger T and larger end you can get
negligible soundness in much better ways
you can directly instantiate with an MPC
that has much better you like you can
make this like one over T choose n which
will already be negligible so you won't
use this in practice at least the ones
that do the digital signatures they
instantiate it for constant number of
parties and do parallel repetition so
for that it like really like this
you still want to work on good soundness
but for negligible soundness there are
other ways to get
[Applause]
[Music]